[Music]
thank you
sometimes I go hold these days
[Music]
where my darling these things
please
foreign
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed this one it was
Believe It or Not hashtag not sponsored
um Katya stakonova of one day spin Fame
sent me a set of these led sock boy from
her online store to try out and review
and I've just been enjoy using them the
Magnolias are in full bloom right now in
DC so I thought I would combine some
elements together along with a track
that I have loved for many many years so
how do you think it turned out let me
know down in the comments and it will
also link to katya's shop down in the
description as well so you can go grab a
set of those if you'd like to meanwhile
I owe a debt of thanks to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and thanks to the non-business Friends
in the channel That is Lane machinsky
and Pekka paclinen thank you both so
very much for supporting my work my
channel and my mission
also this video would not be possible
we're not for the kind support of all of
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down the description
make this and all the videos on this
channel possible thank you one and all
for your very generous support and if
you out there watching are not currently
supporter but would like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you
if you'd like to check out some more of
my flow sessions whether sponsored or
not I'm going to include a link to a
playlist of said videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well either way thanks so much
for watching
um make sure to get outside and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
on on Wednesday goodness peace